[Musica]
pensando a ciò che faccio riflettendo mi
sono talmente tre parole tre parole che
iniziano con la s poi l'altro giorno
confrontandomi con un amico giornalista
mi dice sai che esistono anche tre
parole con la s che devono essere
inserite in un articolo di cronaca nera
per avere successo e sono sesso sangue e
soldi
bene nel mio caso le parole che ho
pensato io sono sofferenza stimolo e
soddisfazione iniziamo con la sofferenza
[Musica]
race across america 5.000 km 50 mila
metri di dislivello e considerata la
gara più dura al mondo si pedala per
circa nove giorni ininterrottamente e
dormendo un'ora ogni 24 e 45 sessioni al
giorno di micro sony da otto minuti
dovetti dove vieni in 30 secondi e per
svegliarti devono scuoterti in modo
violento perché altrimenti staresti lì
per giorni a dormire beh queste
sofferenze allo stato puro è vera
sofferenza i tuoi reni non riescono più
a smaltire tossine che produce ti si
gonfiano le gambe di gonfi come un
pallone non vi cioè non vi dico il
sedere sedere si lacera e comincia a
sanguinare appoggiato sulla sella per 23
ore al giorno
le mani idem si aprono in due e di
viaggiare con le mani fasciate la testa
diventa un macigno diventa pesantissima
il collo non riesce più a sostenerla o
come quando ti vengono le allucinazioni
ai delle allucinazioni pazzesche vedi la
gente attraversati dalla strada dalle 4
del mattino in mezzo al deserto dove tra
un paese e l'altro ci sono 300 km quindi
non esistono queste persone le buche
delle lettere ti sembrano delle
vecchiette boliviane che portano il loro
sacco sulle spalle quindi vedere le cose
pazzesche
oppure come quando ho deciso di partire
dal mare in alcune avventure e
raggiungere la vetta delle montagne
pedalando per ore ore anche 20 ore di
fila ma pensando che quella fosse la
parte più facile la parte più semplice
perché poi si arriva sotto questa
montagna a queste montagne immense che
si chiamano monte bianco monte rosa
kilimangiaro elbrus aconcagua concava
che è alta 7000 metri quando arrivi di
sotto devi correre per 40 chilometri di
scalare e sai che hai il rischio di
andare sotto una slavina nel finire un
crepaccio
il rischio di edema celebrale polmonare
che può portare anche alla morte
bene non voglio farmi compatire per
questo anzi non mai lo farei sarei un
pazzo perché è una cosa che ho scelto io
è una cosa che voglio fare una cosa che
mi stimano e mi stimola perché quello
che è la mia vita
ho quasi 50 anni ma la mia vita si basa
ancora su quello anche se non sono
ragazzino e spero che sia così fino
all'età di 99 anni quando in champ però
scusasse batterò la testa se percorrendo
giù dalla montagna
beh queste queste avventure sono
stimolate ci sono degli stimoli per
portarti sempre avanti adesso vi parlo
di quelli
[Musica]
beh gli stimoli da quelli più banali che
possono essere il pensare di arrivare in
fondo una gara in cima a una vetta di
vincere una gara di battere il tuo tempo
su una salita
queste sono quelli più banali poi sono
quelli che veramente ti toccano non so
avete visto siamo insieme a giovanni
siamo entrati in una miniera in bolivia
appunto si una migliore della gente dove
le persone lavorano per 20 ore al giorno
per di soli 10 dollari
e quando esci da lì non parli per ore
perché dici ti rendi conto di quanto sei
fortunato però questa cosa ti stimola
ferire no cavolo se loro fanno quello io
per me un gioco scalare le montagne a
pedalare per i dieci giorni e quindi non
posso sentire il dolore e quindi è un
grosso stimolo anche quello pensando a
loro pensano la fortuna che ho io
gli stimoli sono i miei figli i miei
ragazzi voglio essere d'esempio per loro
non voglio che percorrono la mia strada
assolutamente però vorrei che capissero
che se intraprendono una strada una
passione un sogno lo portino avanti fino
alla fine che non non è che crescendo i
sogni svaniscono anzi non sono solo dei
bambini sogni i sogni sono degli adulti
per esempio per tutta la vita
e questi questi stimoli poi questo
percorso di sofferenza e di stimoli
porta poi alla fine a una soddisfazione
giustamente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco rivedendo mio figlio
diciamo che questo fa parte dello
stimolo l'ultima race across america
lui mi ha seguito
lo vedevo 4 5 volte durante il giorno e
io cercavo di essere sempre sorridente e
anzi posso questa cosa è un vanto per me
sono felice di dire che non ho mai perso
il sorriso e facendo queste cose facendo
vedere lui che era un sorridente che ero
consapevole di quello che avevo scelto
che non ero lì per faticare ma ero lì
perché stiamo facendo quello che che
c'era chi era uno dei miei sogni e le
soddisfazioni sono quelle è chiaro di
arrivare in fondo qualche cosa dire di
essere stati capaci di aver fatto il
percorso giusto la strada giusta di aver
conosciuto le persone giuste ha
rincontrato le persone giuste di aver
tagliato il traguardo di aver vinto ma
come però non sono un punto d'arrivo per
me sono un punto di ri partenza non
quando arriva in cima alla montagna
innanzitutto è vero che la gloria dura
un paio di secondi da un attimo di
gloria troppo i 16 con sapevo che devi
scendere e quindi sai che devi scendere
quindi devi rimanere concentrato ma sei
anche che quella gloria che durata due
secondi svanisce e anzi si trasforma un
pochino in depressione perché uno poi ha
finito un percorso è arrivato alla fine
di un di una di un sogno di un cammino e
deve trovare subito gli stimoli per
trovarne un altro anzi uno più grosso
uno più d'altronde questa è la vita
queste tre parole sintetizzano un po la
vita di tutti noi e la la sofferenza e
poi lo stimolo che questa strada per
arrivare alla soddisfazione ma non deve
essere poi un punto d'arrivo non
arriveremo ma io non voglio arrivare da
nessuno mai
in fondo voglio sempre che ci siano
degli stimoli sono quelli che ti portano
avanti
ed è quello che voglio ma diciamo
trasferire un po a chi legge il mio
libro ma soprattutto quello che mi
riguarda che sono sono i miei figli io
voglio che questo rimanga a loro che
loro
un giorno mi diranno grazie papà perché
è stato ad esempio per quello che hai
fatto e riprendo la parte finale del mio
libro le ultime righe che dicono ma non
non credo di essere un bravo papà papà
normale cioè penso che sia difficile
essere un bravo papà nessuno alla
pozione magica
però so quello che voglio trasferire
loro facendolo facendolo vedere facendo
essendo ad esempio non solo parlandone
ma facendo io lo dico sempre faccio un
maestro di sci e i miei ragazzi quelli
qui insegno imparano più ta limitazione
che per spiegazione quindi so quello che
voglio insegnare loro e lasciarle loro
spero che loro seguono la propria strada
spero che non non rinunciano mai a
viaggiare a conoscere a seguire i propri
sogni
perché solo così penso che la fatica non
esista davvero
[Applauso]
[Musica]